[Música]
y empezamos nuestro segmento especial de
aquí américa camino a la casa blanca el
espacio semanal para seguir la contienda
entre el presidente de donald trump y el
candidato demócrata joe biden de cara a
las elecciones del 3 de noviembre hoy
vamos a hablar del primer y único debate
entre los vicepresidentes entre mike
pence y kamala harris tras el vergonzoso
primer debate entre el presidente de
donald trump y el candidato demócrata
joe biden marcado por los insultos y las
interrupciones los candidatos a la
vicepresidencia se enfrentaron en un
cara a cara más civilizado y con medidas
de sanidad más estrictas luego de que
trump fuera diagnosticado positivo por
kobe 19 los candidatos fueron separados
por paneles de plexiglás y a la
audiencia se le prohibió quitarse la
mascarilla tras las críticas a los
funcionarios de la casa blanca que se la
retiraron en el debate presidencial
y aunque también hubo interrupciones por
parte del vicepresidente mike pence a la
senadora y candidata kamala harris esta
vez sí hubo discusión de los planes de
gobierno el debate se centró en la
crisis del cob y 19 la vacante en la
corte suprema y la política exterior el
vicepresidente evitó comprometerse con
un intercambio pacífico del poder en
caso de perder las elecciones permítanme
decirles que creo que vamos a ganar
estas elecciones el presidente tú y yo
estamos luchando todos los días en los
tribunales para evitar que yo vaivén y
gama de harris cambian las reglas y cree
en este correo universal en la votación
que creará una gran oportunidad para el
fraude electoral
harris por su parte tuvo momentos
brillantes como cuando atacó a la actual
administración por no condenar a los
grupos de supremacistas blancos y lanzó
duras críticas a trump por su gestión de
el coronavirus y nadie podría imaginarse
si ustedes hubieran sabido el 28 de
enero en vez del 13 de marzo lo que
ellos sabían lo que ustedes habrían
hecho para prepararse ellos sabían y lo
encubrieron el presidente dijo que era
un engaño
el presidente dijo están en un lado si
usan una mascarilla están
del otro lado si no lo hacen entonces
quién ganó en este debate según la
cadena cnn el 58% de las mujeres cree
que harris lo hizo mejor y el 30 que el
vicepresidente los hombres por su parte
cree que fue un empate
vamos a hablar con nuestra corresponsal
en san francisco susana mendoza
susana empiezo por preguntarte cuál es
la importancia del cargo de
vicepresidente en eeuu
hola buenas el cargo de vicepresidente
es muy importante aquí en eeuu
principalmente porque en caso de
ocurrirle algo al presidente sería el
vicepresidente o sea el segundo de
abordo el que tomaría bueno pues el
liderazgo el que asumiría la presidencia
de este país así que es muy importante a
quien se elige para acompañar al líder
de este país tanto es así de hecho que
por ejemplo cuando john kennedy fue
asesinado y los años 60 quien le
reemplazó fue el vicepresidente
clinton de johnson que además bueno
compartía de los ideales del cante toque
cuestiones de derechos civiles y por lo
cual prosiguió el legado de kennedy y
bueno johnson también tuvo otras otras
decisiones peores como por ejemplo
aumentar el número de tropas
y que iban a vietnam pero a pesar de
esto si continúa el legado entonces por
eso es muy importante que los
vicepresidentes si esté en la misma
línea que el presidente aunque sea bueno
más moderado en ciertos temas aparte de
esto por lo general la vicepresidencia
también se ve como una especie de
trampolín a la presidencia una vez que
se termine el cargo del actual
presidente y precisamente entonces
porque este año esta figura ha cobrado
una importancia inédita
bueno porque se considera que hay mucho
más juego más en juego este año quizá
que en otros años electorales y porque
la candidata del partido demócrata
kamala harris es muy conocida en
política y además bastante bien pista en
general en sectores demócratas
harris es una veterana de la justicia de
aquí en california ya que ejerció el
cargo de fiscal general de este estado
hasta el año 2017 igualó con bastantes
luces pero también con algunas sombras
como por ejemplo no querer reformar el
sistema de prisiones en california
creo que harris está bastante en el ojo
político este año también porque va a ir
en es un candidato sino el de mayor edad
hasta ahora uno de los que sí sería
bueno pues de mayor edad con lo cual las
posibilidades de que no llegue a
terminar su mandato serían más grandes
que en otras ocasiones así que la batuta
presidencial y bueno pues caería en
manos d
este año además también precisamente se
enfrentan dos candidatos que no podían
ser más opuestos diametralmente harris
es una mujer de color de padre
afroamericano y madre india liberal
contra mike pence un hombre blanco ultra
conservador y religioso gracias a
nuestra corresponsal en san francisco
susana mendoza por su intervención en
este segmento especial de aquí américa
camino de la cata blanca ya ustedes
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas cuídense mucho del coronavirus
y sigan viendo france24
[Música]